kann weitergehen dazu erst einmal können
wir jedenfalls nicht zur tagesordnung
übergehen das ist menschlich tragisch
ist ein verbrechen wie die frau
bundeskanzlerin gerade gesagt hat es ist
politisch nichts wo man jetzt einfach
weitermachen kann es nicht am ende und
ich finde da der außenminister die
richtigen worte auch heute gefunden auch
sehr klar ist liegt jetzt in russland
auch aufzuklären zu informieren
aus dieser ja auch wenn ich manches
zitat auch heute sehe der trotzigen
haltung rauszukommen also was ist ihre
haltung kann nur 7 weiter gehen ja oder
nein ich habe doch gerade gesagt ich
finde der außenminister hat es richtig
ausgedrückt es hängt jetzt daran ob und
wie russland mit dieser situation umgeht
ob und wie wir mit nord stream zwei
weiter umgehen werden können das ist ja
russland sagt jan rente wir haben ihn
vergiftet deutschland ist schuld
das war ja das ist ja keine radler auf
was warten sie habe ihn zweimal wenn es
ist ja keine 01 oder oder oder hat so
eine abgeschlossene frage sondern am
ende ja ein gesamtbild das verhältnis
die situation zwischen deutschland und
russland europa europäische union und
russland ist es ja auch nicht das erste
mal dass es zu solchen situationen kommt
im übrigen auch ganz anders ukraine und
andere schwierige situationen die in den
letzten jahren gesehen haben und am ende
liegt es tatsächlich an russland gerade
jetzt in diesen tagen und der
bereitschaft aufzuklären ist das ja
haben wir entscheiden herr merz hat
gesagt es brauche ein moratorium
erlassen hat gesagt es muss weiter gehen
trotzdem was ihre haltung
meine haltung ist dass der ball jetzt
erstmal bei russland ist aber russland
hatte nach deutschland ich von ihr haben
in russland ich von russland erwarte
dass da aufgeklärt wird dass informiert
wird dass hintergründe gebracht werden
das ist ja bis jetzt kann nicht
abschließend aufgeklärt dieses
verbrechen das ist es ja nicht es muss
aber aufgeklärt werden
und es hängt sehr stark jetzt von
russland selbst ab und vom verhalten
russlands wie unser generelles
verhältnis zueinander ist deutschland
europäische union zu russland aber eben
auch wie es mit dem stream zwei
weitergeht wenn russland so weiter macht
und sich so äußert wie sich bisher
geäußert haben nämlich dass
deutschland schuld ist das wetter war
vergiftet wurde was ist dann kann nord
stream dann weiter gehen ja oder nein
sage noch einmal sehr klar ist hat
russland vor allem in der hand ob und
wie es mit nordström zwei weitergehen
kann
sie wollen sich darauf nicht festlegen
liegt das daran dass sie mit armin
laschet nein ist nicht ins nichts und
ist einfach daran ist liegt dafür ist
diese frage und zwar nicht zuerst
wirtschaftlich ich finde es gibt keine
wirtschaftliche frage die am ende
wichtige wichtiger sein kann als außen-
und sicherheitspolitische interessen
deutschlands und europas
da gibt es für mich eine ganz andere in
der cdu positionieren sich ja klar jetzt
wäre ein gedanken games zu ende machen
in dieser frage bitte weil ich finde sie
es zu wichtig als dass man sie jetzt zur
parteipolitischen fragen irgendwie
machen sollte es gibt am ende keine
wirtschaftspolitische fragen wie welcher
wichtiger ist als unsere außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen interessen das
ist für mich sehr sehr klar und deswegen
spielt das schon auch zusammen und
deswegen sind auch die prioritäten da
aus meiner sicht jedenfalls sehr sehr
klar
aber trotzdem muss man natürlich auch
den gesamtkontext sehen
da geht es um viel in allen bereichen
vor allem aber auch für händler
wahrnehmen und für die frage wie
russland
dort in dieser konkreten situation
agiert übrigens nicht zum ersten mal
nach allem was wir wissen und deswegen
sage ich noch einmal liegt jetzt auch an
russland wie es weitergeht